it's a distinct honor for me to
introduce that dr. Ellen fields Yellen
is how his investigator and Rebecca
Collins field professor at the
Rockefeller University and Ellen is a
world leader in skin biology with her
current research interests focus on skin
stem cells all the years Ellen has made
the seminal contributions to this
largest organ in your body and its
associated genetic disorders she
published more than 250 papers many of
them are in nature science and sale and
Alain's literature's papers really
represents to me the most important part
of the modern literature in skin biology
and if you want to write any topic skin
biology it's impossible for you to avoid
citing Ellen's papers so just to refresh
dr. Jim Bosmans this morning's
introduction of dr. Eric Kandel
Elaine is without a doubt the king of
skin biology so in fact the Ellen's
contribution goes much beyond her own
research compliment she over the years
has earned many talented postdoctoral
fellows and students who have moved on
to establish their own independent
research careers and 2000 Ballentine
aqua CO and Valerie host we are
currently under your faculty
moreover throughout her career ellen is
devoted to service the scientific
community and among many leadership
positions that she has heard in various
professional societies committees
and foundations she is a past president
of the American Society of cell biology
a past president of the Harvey Society
and the current president of the
International Society for stem-cell
research so in the past few years I have
had the privilege to work closely with
Elaine in the stem cell society and I'm
always in awe of her tireless effort and
her lead
chef's skills so because it lands many
contributions she has received numerous
honors and was just to set a few most
recent ones she was a recipient of the
National Medal of Science in 2009 and
she was the North American laureate also
lol UNESCO award last year in 2010 and
this year she's about to receive the
grant Albany price event a member of the
National Academy of Sciences the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences
the Institute of Medicine and the
American Society philosophical Society
so people often mark that beauty is only
skin-deep
however when it comes to Alliance
research beauty is truly lying in the
skin even we are delighted to have you
here to share with us
thank you I fan and and happy birthday a
happy anniversary I was trying to decide
what should I call it in any case this
is just a real honor to participate in
this symposium we have so many great
scientists up on the podium and so many
great scientists in the audience so for
me it's this is I've been looking
forward to this for some time I also
thought I'd maybe pick up where - left
off and as my role now as current
president for the International Society
for stem-cell research I have had a
pleasure to work with - he's been our
program chair for this coming at
International annual meeting and it's
going to be held in June 15th through
the 18th this year in Toronto so for
anyone who's interested in stem cells
please do come it's a terrific meeting
and one of your stars and stem cell
research here has organized it so do
support us so today I thought I would
give you a little bit of background on
how I became a skin biologist and
specifically how I got interested in
stem cells and before I start let's just
make sure we're on the same page of what
we think a stem cell is and basically
stem cells have three criteria these are
often slow cycling not always slow
cycling progenitor cells they give rise
to rapidly proliferating progenitor
cells and then through a series of
various different cues they eventually
will go on to make a tissue and this
overall process in morphogenesis
requires that the stem cells are
long-term for the lifetime of the animal
that they undergo the ability to self
renew and that they can give rise to at
least one tissue and whether or not they
are slow cycling fast cycling whether
they
give rise to many different tissues is
something that can apply to some but not
all stem cells so my laboratory has used
skin as a model system really for
studying for stem cell biology tissue
morphogenesis and cancer and we do so
for some simple reasons this is the most
readily accessible source of stem cells
it's also the most abundant source of
stem cells the lineages of the
epithelium that you see in blue here are
spatially and temporally well-defined
and one of the most fascinating aspects
that I think is an illustration of what
stem cells do is that the skin begins as
a single layer of unspecified epithelium
and then through a series of different
external cues and intrinsic use now
either stratifies to form the epidermis
of our skin forms the hair follicle
forms sweat glands or form sebaceous
glands how one single stem cell can
undergo these very different tissue
organizations and respond to different
cues in the context of its tissue and
organ I think it's really a fascinating
aspect of biology in the adult our skin
is constantly undergoing turnover every
four weeks you've got a brand new
epidermis you'll be happy to know on
your body surface and of course if
you're lucky throughout the course of
your lifetime your hair follicles are
not only going to undergo rest but they
are also going to grow at least
sometimes for some length of time and at
least some and and so one of the aspects
that really got me into becoming an
epidermal biologist many years ago is
that the epithelial stem cells of the
body can be maintained in cold in
culture without losing their stemness
and again if you're trained as I was as
a chemist and a biochemist and you
really want to understand how things
work inside cells and inside
tissues then this was the beautiful
system to study when we also think about
cancer as Harold has touched upon as
well as Liz and many of the other
speakers today we are mindful of the
fact that basal and squamous cell
carcinomas of the skin are the most
prevalent cancers worldwide so back when
I was a postdoctoral fellow at MIT many
years back I worked with Howard green
and Howard pioneered the ability to
culture human epidermal stem cells in
the laboratory he adapted the use of
these stem cells for the treatment of
burn patients one of the first and
long-standing over a 30-year history of
a successful use of stem cells in a
clinical setting and one of the major
breakthroughs was the recognition that
epithelial cells rely upon certain
factors by mesenchymal cells in order to
be able to maintain their properties
this served as the paradigm for then the
development the subsequent development
of culturing of embryonic stem cells in
the laboratory which also utilized a
feeder layer for their maintenance it
also took various different branches
Michaela DeLuca another former
postdoctoral fellow in the green
laboratory learned how to culture
corneal epithelial stem cells adapting
some of the protocols the Green had used
for epidermal stem cells in order to be
able to treat certain types of corneal
blindness particularly those of acid
burn which are a very prevalent problem
in many parts of the world this is an
example of taking the blind-eye and
treating it with cultured corneal stem
cells that came from the good eye and
this is the result and the result is
quite remarkable and again we often
think about stem cell therapy as
something that is on the horizon
something that hasn't happened yet in
the
dear Makayla DeLuca published a 10-year
success over a hundred different
patients treated with this type of
therapy with their blindness cured and
so again this is another successful use
of stem cells in a clinical setting and
I think for my own field one of the
problems that we face in convincing the
public and governments around the world
to move this field of regenerative
medicine forward is really an
educational one and that is to give
examples of successes and allow people
to recognize that really starting with
organ therapy many many years even
before these that there's a long
standing history of the use of stem
cells in regenerative medicine the kinds
of questions that my laboratory is
currently interested in with regards to
these types of problems is what happens
for instance when both eyes are blind
when there are no corneal stem cells
could we perhaps use for instance skin
stem cells and if we understood enough
about the differences in similarities
between corneal stem cells in skin stem
cells epidermal stem cells or hair
follicle stem cells then perhaps we
could reprogram those skin or hair
follicle stem cells into becoming
corneal stem cells that's a really small
baby step given the pioneering giant
step that
Shinya Yamanaka and his co-workers
conducted several years ago when they
demonstrated that you could take skin
fibroblasts and introduce four different
transcription factors into those cells
and convert them all the way back to
embryonic like stem cells so I think
these types of approaches are realistic
approaches and ones that really rely on
our understanding of the basic science
of these epidermal or hair follicle stem
cells so when I started my own
laboratory many years back we took a
molecular approach a very
fundamental basic science approach we
didn't understand any of the biology
about these stem cells and so the
initial start that I gave to my
laboratory was basically to make a cDNA
library and start to clone out and
identify some of the markers of these
stem cells where we could take these
cells out in an ax clonal passage
instead miss so at that time it was just
at the cusp of DNA recombinant
technology and we didn't have tools
there were no databases to tell us what
probes to use to screen library to
identify different markers we didn't
have any marker knowledge and so what we
did was basically to utilize a probe to
the exact same messenger RNA and
hybridize that to the same messenger RNA
that we had used to make the library and
basically take advantage of the fact
that the strongly expressing markers of
these cells would in fact be the most
strongly hybridizing on from the cDNA
and so this really led us to identify
very abundantly expressed genes that
were present in these epidermal stem
cells and that led us to the realization
that keratin 5 in keratin 14 are not
only good markers for human epidermal
stem cells but they happen to be markers
for virtually all of the stem cells of
various different types of stratified
epithelia that are expressed in
different parts of the body so this
started to give us markers and part of
my laboratory was interested in the
proteins themselves what do these
keratin proteins do and from that
perspective what we showed was that
these form of very robust cytoskeletal
architecture within these stem cells and
we basically studied the properties of
how these keratins
assemble into intermediate filaments
both in cells and culture
and also under in a test tube by looking
under the electron microscope we also
identified that the basic subunit
structure of these proteins was or of
these filaments was a coiled called
heterodimer an obligatory heterodimer
and we began to introduce mutations to
understand what domains of these
proteins were important in forming this
beautiful architecture but at that time
I began to wonder and people in my
laboratory began to wonder that these
were the major structural proteins of
these cells the globin various different
mutations in globin gave rise to such
diseases as sickle-cell anemia and the
thalassemias we felt that there must be
human disorders of keratin how did we go
about finding them and this was the
challenge because we couldn't really
tell by looking underneath the
microscope either here or here what the
consequences to physiology might be of
these various different defects and so
at this point in time we decided that we
needed transgenic mice to give us an
indication of what might be the case and
so here again it was just at the cusp of
transgenic mouse technology where a few
different laboratories around the
country were using this approach we went
to another university to learn the
approach and basically took our mutant
in this case keratin 14 gene and
introduced it into the germline of these
mice the mice started out okay but as
they started walking around the cage
they started to get blisters and that
then led us as we dug deeper and deeper
into what the paradigm for what an
intermediate filament disorder might
look like the stem cells located in the
innermost layer of the epidermis were
completely degenerated there were clumps
or aggregates of these filament proteins
that were appearing in the cells and
that was causing a site alysus or
mechanical fragility of these cells so
then we needed to know what type of
mic human humans have who if they were
to exist and so at this point we needed
to know something about Dermatology and
I was trained from a basic science
perspective so we went across the street
and got a dermatology textbook and began
thumbing our way through and it was a
surprise when my student and postdoc and
I came across this disorder
epidermolysis bullosa simplex a
autosomal dominant blistering disorder
that humans get and this child simply
from washing his face and so this was a
mechanical fragility blistering and
basically gave us an understanding of
what an intermediate filament disease
looks like it was taking a completely
different approach the positional
cloning approach was always to choose
your disease and then work your way down
to the gene which when defective would
cause that disorder as a basic scientist
and protein biochemists we wanted to
choose our proteins and go in the
reverse direction in this case that
happened to work and the advantage of
taking this approach was that there were
also a variety of other perve areas
different human diseases that fit this
paradigm the first that we worked out
was epidermal lytic hyperkeratosis a
disease that doesn't look very much like
the other disease but at the ultra
structural level now it was a super
basal or the differentiating cells that
showed these clumps or aggregates of
keratin filament and this fragility of
of the cells and back when I was a
postdoctoral fellow I had demonstrated
that as keratin as epidermal cells
undergo commitment to differentiate they
down regulate one set of keratins and
switch on another set of keratin and so
this paradigm for differential
expression of keratin and different
epithelial tissues of our body and
basically gave what became a long list
of not only epithelial disorders of
keratin but also disorders of other
intermediate filaments expressed in
other tissue types and the last one that
we
Don was to work out the genetic basis of
a generalized myopathy that turned out
to be due to defects in Desman
intermediate filament proteins so this
just illustrates for you the approach of
taking this reverse genetic approach
that now seems rather commonplace but at
the time was challenging particularly
since we didn't know anything about
dermatology nor did we know anything
about transgenic mouse technology so as
we began to work on keratins another
approach to this was to focus on the
promoters and how these genes are
transcriptionally regulated because this
really was getting at the crux of how do
we understand how stem cells exit the
cell cycle and commit to differentiate
and maybe we could use this as a
paradigm for understanding new insights
into stem cells and particularly into
tissue development and so along these
lines we were particularly intrigued by
the fact that the skin the epidermal
stem cells that have been used for skin
grafting made beautiful epidermis but
the patients never made hair follicles
nor did they sweat and so we've known
for all these 30 years that there must
be other sources of stem cells within
the skin and the challenge for us is
where are those stem cells and could we
use our carrot and promoters in order to
be able to try to identify where they
might be
we took a page from some 1960s work
where researchers had done what they
call a pulse chase experiment in order
to identify relatively infrequently set
dividing cells within the body at the
time researchers were taking radioactive
thymidine and giving my suppose of
radioactive thymidine those cells that
are actively dividing eat whether
they're slowly dividing or quickly
dividing will incorporate the radio
labeled thymidine
and then if you simply start chasing
where that radioactivity is going after
time every time the cells divide then
they're going to dilute out that label
by a factor of two so they're very
rapidly dividing cells are going to soon
divide and lose the label whereas the
infrequently dividing cells are going to
retain the label the non-dividing cells
of course will never incorporate the
label in the first place and so at this
point then we simply combined the two
approaches and we adapted a classical
nucleotide pulse chase experiment to
mark the infrequently dividing cells
within tissues figuring that those might
be where the stem cells a characteristic
of the stem cells and so here is the
experiment then we made two different
transgenic mice one of them was
expressing histone H to be GFP under the
control of a tetracycline regulator the
other was taking our keratin promoter
and using it to drive a tetracycline
regulatory transcription factor so that
in the absence of tetracycline the
mouse's body surface is green and now
all we have to do is add tetracycline to
the animals diet to turn the gene off
and now every time the cells divide that
are rapidly dividing they're going to
dilute out the label and what we should
be left with which is what we were left
with after a chase period is simply
these cells located within the hair
follicle in a region where a classical
nucleotide post-chaise experiments had
identified these by radioactivity so the
advantages is that now that they're
fluorescently labeled we can start to do
experiments with these cells I just
point out that the way in which we
designed the experiment was to allow
other researchers to take advantage of
these mice and utilize their favorite
promoters to identify label retaining
cells and their favorite cell types or
tissues and so this several years ago
was several different laboratories
utilize this to identify him
what extent sells and actually identify
not only the classical Hamato poetic
stem cells but also one that had been
overlooked by classical nucleotide
post-chaise experiments because they
were so infrequently dividing that the
radio labeled nucleotide pulses failed
to pick up those cells those cells
however were very important cells
because they're utilized upon severe
injury and they can actually give rise
to the classical hematopoietic stem
cells in response to injuries so these
are really the gold standard cells that
are set aside for injury repair and the
technology now has been used for
isolating the dental tooth stem cells as
well as the breast epithelial stem cells
so one of the challenges is that a slow
cycling cell does not necessarily mean
that you've got a stem cell and so we
needed to come up with methodology to be
able to demonstrate whether or not these
cells were actually stem cells the way
in which we did this was to use a tissue
regeneration assay which is the
essential assay of what stem cells do
and so here we could take advantage of
the ability to use fluorescence
activated cell sorting to purify these
cells and then we could take advantage
of Howard Greene's methods to culture
these cells only in this case we adapted
them to culture hair follicle stem cells
and now we could pick individual
colonies each one derived from a single
label retaining cell do a full thickness
graft onto a nude Mouse and ask whether
or not these animals were now capable of
making hair and this prompted then a
number of phone calls people suddenly
took an interest in our research
irrespective of whether they were
scientists or not more often they were
non scientist than scientists and they
still continue to call us to this day
and we're still not doing clinical
trials yet I do
haven't ever gone back to medical school
so they also make epidermis sebaceous
glands as well as hair follicles and
again I think this illustrates just the
power enormous power that stem cells
have to make tissue because all of these
hairs and all of this tissue is made
from one single cell so we also looked
at how cells become slow cycling how
early do stem cells form within tissues
and we learned that the niche form is
very early on in embryogenesis one of my
MD PhD students who's now in clinical
residency at Harvard Medical School
basically looked earlier in early in
embryogenesis and we learned that even
before the hair follicle has finished
growing in the first round of
morphogenesis already there are cells
that begin to accumulate in the upper
portion of the hair follicle that are
less frequently cycling than all of the
other cells within the skin we know that
these are in fact the adult stem cells
because we can chase them all the way
out to the adult tissue so this then
allows us to learn and gain new insights
about stem cells and their behavior but
of course we can also use this knowledge
to be able to really get the entire
profile of what genes are preferentially
expressed in the hair follicle stem
cells versus their progeny versus their
epidermal proliferative progeny or
versus their comitted progeny the cells
that are going to give rise to the hair
hair and the channel that the hair sits
in so from these types of analyses and
we now use about seven different markers
positive and negative markers so our
profiles are getting better and better
with every marker what we've learned is
that there's a whole slew of different
transcription factors that are
preferentially upregulated in these
cells there's a G coupled protein
receptor LGR v which haunts Cleaver's
has studied in the intestinal stem cell
niche
identified as an important intestinal
stem cell marker that too is
overexpressed in the hair follicle stem
cells and integrins an issue that fiona
watt and her coworkers identified many
years ago as being preferentially
expressed or upregulated in cells with
proliferative capacity those hair
follicle stem cells to express higher
levels of these integrins curiously when
they're sitting in a quiescent niche the
various different external cues or
internal cues tend to be down regulated
sonic hedgehog wince etc are
characteristics that are upregulated as
stem cells commit to transit amplifying
progeny that are now receiving cues to
make the hair shaft but they're not
characteristics of the quiescent stem
cells so are these also key genes for
stemness and one of the ways that we've
utilized to be able to address that is
to take our caret and promoters and to
be able to link them to Creary common
ace to be able to make conditional
knockout mice and we've also been able
to use these as new markers of stem
cells so this just shows you an example
of sox9 one of those transcription
factors where you can see that very
early on in the development of the hair
follicle these cells are already
starting to appear you can almost tell
that these are going to be the new hair
follicle stem cell niche and they very
soon after appear that way
we can also use a technology known as
lineage tracing which is very popular
among the stem cell arena where in this
case we take sox9 promoter to drive Cree
recombination and we made it to a mouse
that is expressing or could express Lac
Z under the control of a generic rosa 26
promoter if indeed this stop codon
that's preventing it from doing so was
excised it can be selectively excite by
the activation of Creary Khamenei's
and so they're after all of the progeny
of cells that initially started to
express sox9
are now marked by beta galactosidase
expression so you can very soon realize
using this approach that the entire hair
follicle is basically forming as a
consequence of the sox9 expressing cells
so once these cells are expressed then
they systematically replace all of the
other cells in the hair follicle the
sebaceous gland is the very last
structure in tissue morphogenesis that
forms within the skin and that too is
entirely derived from sox9 positive
cells the epidermis curiously however
has its own resident population of stem
cells and that's perhaps not surprising
from the work that I showed you that was
pioneered by Howard Greene however in a
wound situation things change over what
they do in a normal situation in a one
situation now cells from within the hair
follicle move upward to repair the
missing stem cells in the epidermis and
that illustrates something that occurs
not only in neonatal skin but also an
adult skin it illustrates a very
important principle that we see over and
over again whether we're looking at how
matter what extent cells or whether we
look at skin stem cells or intestinal
stem cells and that is how stem cells
behave in response to injury can be
broader in specificity than how they
behave in their normal setting in the
normal setting within the skin there are
resident stem cells within the epidermis
within the sebaceous gland within the
sweat gland within the hair follicle but
in response to wound healing
now cells can adopt a somewhat broader
fate and I think that's an interesting
facet of stem cells and once we'd
certainly like to be able to harness in
the future sox9 is also a key
transcription factor where now we can
use our keratin promoters and a blade
sox9 expression in the skin epithelium
and you can see that the hair follicles
don't form on this map
sebaceous glands also don't form and the
epidermis is slow to heal its wounds so
the wound response is really taking
advantage of all stem cells in the
vicinity almost a 911 cells we've also
demonstrated using conditional knockout
strategies that all of these other
transcription factors are essential
factors for maintaining stemness in the
hair follicle and we've also
demonstrated using a double knockout of
the DNA methyltransferase for the
polycomb protein chromatin repressors
that those two are essential in
maintaining the properties of stem cells
and their progenitors and so the current
studies in my laboratories regarding
transcription is now to take advantage
of our ability to be able to purify not
quite buckets but at least sufficient
quantities of stem cells in their
quiescent state in their activated state
and in their committed state and be able
to do in vivo chromatin mapping and we
now are beginning to get a picture of
how the chromatin is changing under
these various different changes in
response to the physiological conditions
of the skin epithelium and I think this
is going to give us new insights ones
that perhaps are not so much afforded
for when one looks in culture where we
know that when we take cells and put
them into culture that they change the
transcriptional complexes and programs
that are normally expressed in the
tissue and so we're taking an in vivo
approach it's taken us a longer time to
get there but I think it's giving us a
really good picture and really good
insights into what are the key factors
that are playing a role in making these
changes in gene expression over time and
this really then emphasizes what I think
is the beauty of the hair follicle is
that the hair follicle undergoes the
cyclic abouts
of periods where the hair follicle is
just sitting there resting and then in
response to mizenko
epithelial stimuli provided by this
structure called the dermal papillae the
new hair growth begins the hair follicle
grows downward the hair shaft grows
upward and then all of a sudden these
cells down at the base the committed
cells which are called matrix cells in
close contact now with the dermal
papillae which is moved downward away
from the stem cells now ends up all of a
sudden undergoing a Peto psious don't
yet understand exactly what grinds it to
a halt but it grinds it to a halt and
wipes out the transit amplifying
population of cells with that the entire
hair follicle at the base retracts
upward until it comes back again to rest
so the growth phase requires stem cells
in action and the resting phase
unfortunately gets longer and longer and
longer as we age and so if we could
really understand what drives the hair
cycle which we're now beginning to
understand then we might be able to
correct this little problem that some
people feel is a bigger problem that we
think so
with regards to understanding what turn
stem cells on what we've done is to look
at this long extended period of rest The
Heretic hair follicles in the mouse skin
are fairly well synchronized so we can
look at a whole bunch of hair follicles
all sitting there resting and for three
weeks period of time if you do a short
pulse with any kind of nucleotide analog
nothing gets incorporated in this big
hair follicle bulge stem cell niche in
this little pocket of stem cells at the
base of the niche called the hair germ
or in the dermal papillae but then way
at the end of that process if we now
start to look at what happens in a short
nucleotide pulse cells at the very base
of the Bulge in this hair germ
structures start to incorporate brdu
these are always the cells that are
closest to the mesenchymal stimulus what
controls this transition well we've
studied the epithelial mesenchymal
boss talk and when Valentina Greco was
in my laboratory what we did was to
isolate the cells and profile the cells
both from the bone structure the hair
germ structure and the mesenchymal the
dermal papillae structure during that
entire three-week period of time and
what we learned is that there's a lot of
transcriptional activity and cross talk
going on between the cells closest to
the mesenchymal stimulus and the
mesenchymal stimulus the mesenchymal
stimulus is producing increasing levels
of BMP inhibitors and the epithelial
cells are producing increasing
expression levels of wins these are not
the only places where these different
external cues are coming from but they
play a role in stem cell activation and
at that same stage where you start to
see proliferation you also start to see
nuclear beta catenin and nuclear beta
catenin is the downstream target at the
win signal and is playing a role as a
transcriptional cofactor so we now then
have a good understanding of that
transition between quiescent activation
we've also transcriptionally profiled
the stem cells in silence and in action
and so we know what changes in gene
expression are taking place and how they
might control the cell cycle and they
and the activation of these stem cells
we also have shown that at elevated
levels of wind signal that many of these
same genes are basically expressed so we
can also utilize our label retaining
cells to recognize that every time those
cells once they get activated every time
they divide they're going to dilute out
the label by a factor of two and so we
can now start using that to learn how
many divisions do these cells undergo
and where do they go when stem cells get
activated and the results are very clear
where once they get activated every one
of these cells of the emerging hair
follicle have epifluorescence that is
high and the only cells that have it
that are higher are those
cells that came from the Bulge in the
hair germs so basically that
demonstrates again using another
principle that these stem cells in vivo
without injury or the like just in the
normal hair cycle are contributing to
hair tissue regeneration
we've also then utilized this technology
and coupled it with a series of
staggered nucleotide pulse chases to
basically reconstruct a movie of once
stem cells are activated in exit their
niche where do they go and how do they
contribute to tissue and when along that
lineage do they stop becoming stem cells
and become a committed cell and again
they hair follicles since everything is
spatially and linearly temporally
defined allows us to be able to answer
those questions so it's effectively what
we're doing by doing these staggered
pulse chase experiments is to create
snapshots of the stem cells and the stem
cells as they become these transit
amplifying population of cells what
that's told us is actually that the
whole process of hair regeneration is
one that is driven by these mesenchymal
epithelial stimuli that basically
determine a gradient of proliferation
from the top down and the stem cells get
activated but it's only briefly that
they get activated they go back to
dormancy as the mesenchymal stimulus
moves away the cells that begin moving
further down along the hair follicle get
activated but they chew withdraw from
the cell cycle as the mesenchymal
stimulus goes away and only those cells
now down at the base continue to
proliferate and they're proliferating in
a gradient of rates of proliferation
we've also been able to define when the
hair follicle stem cells stop becoming a
stem cell in this line and that's given
us some very interesting results in
addition we've monitored what happens
when there's a line of 85 cells between
the stem cell niche and the committed
progeny
all of a sudden the destructive phase
sets in and the transit amplifying pool
undergoes a pet OSIS there's a lot of
cells along here and many of them have
divided only a few times they're still
maintaining their stemness properties
and we've shown that they home back to
the stem cell niche we've also shown
however that there are some cells that
have gone too far they still have some
stem cell characteristics but they are
not stem cells they're never going to be
stem cells again and they too home back
to their niche so what's going on
we've learned that basically the cells
in red are the stem cells the cells in
green our cells that had gone too far
along the lineage when the destructive
phase set in and somehow they were
spared from ap ptosis and they go back
to this niche why would a tissue ever do
things this way now the hair follicle is
weird I admit but basically this is
really weird and I think it turns out to
be applicable generally to different
types of stem cell biology so the first
one is not so applicable the first
reason why this inner layer of cells
goes back to the niche and basically is
never going to be stem cells again is
that they have their anchoring that old
hair in place when you think about your
hair growing your hair is growing out
from the surface of your skin if that
process just continues when the
destructive phase sets in and all of
your hair follicles are synchronized
you're gonna undergo cyclic abouts of
baldness with hair growth and baldness
and you think about an animal in the
wild like a grizzly bear and that's not
a good thing for those animals and so
you've got to have a way of anchoring
the hairs in place and what happens is
that by virtue of still maintaining some
of the stem cell characteristics these
cells we think recognize when they get
back to the Bulge to stop and they are
short circuited in their differentiation
and begin to produce these very strongly
adhesive signals that basically
Anker this hair you've also noticed that
whenever you pluck your hair
your hairs regrow the reason why that
happens and it's really annoying but the
reason why that happens is basically
because when you're plucking the hair
you're plucking out all those green
cells and this gets to the second
critical part of what these stem cells
do what these stem cells do is they
start making a potent inhibitory cue
that is signaling to the stem cells in
red saying stop proliferating and
basically that potent inhibitory cue
when you pluck those cells out is
missing and the stem cells basically
automatically go back into action we
demonstrated that this is the case and
the absence of mechanical plucking by
virtue of using an ablation technique
that I won't go into but if you oblate
the green cells the red cells will be
stimulated to proliferate and they
automatically go into a new hair cycle
even under conditions where the existing
hair is there and you haven't applied
mechanical stress in contrast the red
cells if you basically a blade part of
those cells it's only the few remaining
red cells that are stimulated to
proliferate the green cells could care
less about becoming a stem cell again so
we now have a good understanding of what
those inhibitory cues are and I'd like
now to say that we think that this might
be an important process because think
about any type of stem cell in any type
of Anish what I've told you so far is
that there's a stem cell niche that has
stem cells they received the mesenchymal
epithelial cues wynt signals and BMP
inhibitors it says go make the hair hair
follicle the hair grows for a while then
the whole system grinds to a halt tissue
production stops those cells that still
have stem cell characteristics that have
gone out of the niche home back again
and remain as stem cells and re utilized
and some cells from the differentiating
shuh basically also home back but
they'll never be stem cells again and
they have impose a stop sign so this not
only tells us how the hair follicle
cycle works but it also suggests to us
that the stem cell niche is this niche
of various external cues that are
inhibitory cues and internal cues and
that are stimulatory and a series of
different balances then ultimately lead
to the activation of the stem cells
tissue gets made think about an injury
situation the stem cells are silent
there's an injury you need to make
tissue but it's just as important to
figure out when to stop making tissue as
it is to figure out when to start you
can't simply continue to make tissue and
so I think every single tissue of our
body has to know when to activate stem
cells and when to turn them off and what
better way to turn them off than to use
cells that are committed along the
lineage to send out that negative
feedback loop to be able to stop the
tissue from stop the stem cells in
action another interesting aspect is
that those negative that negative signal
is missing in cancer the hair is not
there in a basal cell carcinoma or a
squamous cell carcinoma and in fact I'll
finish along these notes because what
we've been learning as we study the
mechanisms of stem cell activation is
that every time we alter that pathway
what we end up with is basically a
cancer model and that's turned us into
cancer biologists to really understand
that basically cancers are harnessing
stem cell activation cues they may not
come from stem cells and that's a
completely open debate but they
certainly harness those cues and the
first example of that was now over a
decade ago where we elevated levels of
stabilized beta-catenin in these mice
prompting additional calls from
additional non-scientists but basically
they really didn't care that these
animals over time developed tumors we
tried to tell people
and we utilize this to be able to work
out the genetic basis of this type of
human hair tumor which has the majority
of its cases as having stabilized
mutations in beta catenin but we also
see this saw this with BMP receptor
knockouts with tgf-beta receptor
knockouts and so we're really interested
now in what this relationship is between
the cancer stem cells and that are
making an abnormal tumor and the
relationship to normal stem cells and so
along these lines we figured that
there's so much ambiguity about where
stem cells came from that we haven't
addressed that problem but what we have
addressed is basically taking again a
functional approach to identifying where
are the cancer stem cells within a tumor
where are the tumor initiating cells and
just by purifying without throwing away
any of the populations of cells as
you're fractionating them we've
systematically gone through and tested
all the pools using secondary and
tertiary tumor initiation and we're now
down to single cells that we can take
that when we introduce serially into
mice will give rise to the tumor and
that to me says we've got cancer stem
cells and so it's interesting now to
start to compare those properties of the
stem cells with their normal
counterparts and identify what those
differences are and we've also done this
on different genetic backgrounds because
again whether the extent to which a stem
cell is predicated or its behavior and
gene expression is predicated on the
basis of its mutations versus its micro
environment I think is an important
problem in Kenton cancers in cancers and
in treating cancers so ultimately in
trying to identify the significance of
these 150 genes that are up and down
regulated either in comparing cancer
stem cells with normal stem cells or in
comparing quiescent stems
- activated stem cells - committed stem
cells clearly this process is laborious
and if we're going to simply use
conditional targeting technology over
and over again it's going to take a long
time to sift our way through a hundred
and fifty genes and so we've been
working on approaches that will allow us
to systematically knock down genes in
mice where we can draw the parallels to
human disease quite quickly but sticking
to mice only expediting the process of
gene knockdown we think we've got a
method now that is helping us to do so
and what we do is to take advantage of
the fact that right after gastrulation
the skin is exists as a single layer of
layer of unspecified progenitor cells
and taking advantage of the fact that
lentivirus
only goes into the very first cell layer
that it sees and so if we capture that
stage what we can do is basically put
mom under anesthesia and pull out the
string of embryos one by one and inject
the amniotic sac so it's a completely
non-invasive technique for the embryo
but basically we've been able to really
get very high titer lentivirus
into in very efficient way into the skin
epithelium again not using any tissue
specific promoters anymore not using
anything fancy other than taking
advantage of the broad library shRNA
library and this just shows you an
example where we read marked the
lentiviral vector once it gets
integrated it's stabili propagated
surprisingly it's not turned off in the
adults so we can monitor this into the
adult and basically you can see that the
dermis is completely untouched even
though we're not using an epidermal
promoter anymore so this is
revolutionized how we think about and
how we approach different problems of
skin biology we can now take whole
pathways as opposed to simply focusing
on a specific gene and we can clearly
very rapidly now remove redundancies
which is one of the problems in the
mouse genome it also allows us now to
begin to release system
radically work our way through cancer
stem cancer-causing genes when altered
in their when altering the behavior of
tissue because we can now set up growth
index assays where we simply take a red
virus as a control and our knockdown
marked in green and basically for a
tumor suppressor that has a growth
advantage when knocked down we now end
up with a larger number of green cells
to red cells over time and with one that
is an oncogene when it's knocked down we
basically end up with the reverse and so
we're doing whole scale genome screens
now basically in the same vein that
people do in worms and mice only now
unwarned and nematode only now doing
this in mice and so right now we're in
the midst of those studies but I think
this really gives us a new approach to
thinking about doing classical types of
genetic screens or perhaps unclasps of
genetic screens but accomplishing the
same aim so that's really where we've
come with skin as a model system for
studying it didn't take it took us a lot
longer than it took samson and delilah
to realize the power of hair but over
the years we've become a real here
aficionados and and I suppose one of
these days I should really listen to NIH
with the call to clinical applications
and try to really seriously work on
baldness but for now I'm still immersed
in the basic science I have to say so
that's really all I wanted to say except
for again thank you very much and I
appreciate the invitation and happy
birthday happy anniversary